[Musique]
dès que j'ai découvert ces papiers en
fait j'ai tout de suite fait le lien et
je me suis dit mais voilà en fait c'est
ça il faut que je crie ma collection
poésie sur sur ses papiers et donc c'est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai créé un petit
objet où on a un poète ou une poétesse
un poème est une graine
[Musique]
je les dépose et comme mon déposerait
une une marque finalement non voilà
parce que parce que j'ai effectivement
je pense avoir été un moment donné la
seule à faire ce lien comme ça donc je
vois là je le défends aussi comme étant
ma création même si ce n'est pas moi qui
fabriquait papier par exemple sur la
poésie je trouve que ça marche très très
bien parce qu'effectivement on peut très
bien se dire voilà on va affronter un
poème récité on va la voir en mémoire il
va être en nous à l'état de traces mais
en même temps on va voir transformer les
choses on va avoir créé de la fleur à
l'endroit où il y avait des mots
une municipalité qui m'a commandait des
petites comptines sur graines de
carottes pour les enfants de maternelle
de la ville et j'ai assisté à une
expérience extraordinaire c'est vrai que
j'ai vu les enfants vraiment croire que
les mots poucet et ça j'en ai un
souvenir
yves blouin